-Like I said, one of our guests
tonight is Colin Quinn,
the great Colin Quinn,
and he has a book out
called "Overstated"
where he basically roasts
every state in the U.S.
It's funny, and you can
just read it in any order.
It's a good book.
Well, I wanted to put him
to the test,
so now it's time for
"Overstated with Colin Quinn."
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ Overstated, overstated,
overstated, overstated ♪
♪ Yeah ♪
-Colin, Colin, are you there?
Oh, I see you.
-Oh, yes.
-Wow, yeah.
Colin, I thought we could
go through some states
and you can give them
a quick roasting.
Does that sound okay?
-Sure.
-First of all,
how are you doing?
Are you okay?
-Oh, I don't know
why you would --
You should have
said that before...
-I know, I know, I know, I know.
I understand.
I know, but I --
I admit -- Sorry.
-Hey, you just started this.
-I know, but it wasn't
on the teleprompter.
But, yeah, you look good.
I hope you're okay.
-Oh, it wasn't on
the teleprompter.
-It's not about
being a big shot.
That's the way it works.
Acting like I'm trying to --
-No, I wasn't
calling you a big shot.
I was saying -- I was making
a dumb joke that,
"It wasn't on the teleprompter.
I couldn't read it."
[ Laughter ]
Sorry.
-Oh, my God.
I guess we started with
the first roast already.
Oh, my gosh.
How about this, Colin?
Arizona.
What could you say
about Arizona?
-I call them the Instagram state
'cause they're beautiful
but empty.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
-How about -- How about Ohio?
-Ohio's like the middle,
like the nice --
They're like your nice friend
that waits in the car
while you're hooking up
with somebody in the house.
They'll sit there and wait
to drive you home.
[ Laughter ]
-Florida.
-Florida's the hot mess
that you want to hang out with
but you always end up
getting arrested with them.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay, last state.
Pennsylvania.
-I don't want to do Pennsylvania
'cause you're gonna feel like
it's an attack on you,
but it's not.
-Why?
-Alright, I'll do it.
But don't be paranoid, okay?
My joke is, it's a state
that kind of, like, started,
it almost fell apart,
then it came back strong.
You might call it like
the "Fever Pitch" of states,
I call it.
That's the nickname.
[ Laughter ]
I didn't make up that nickname.
That's the state nickname.
It's on the license plate.
-Why would I even do this?
How do I not
take that personally?
Give it up for Colin Quinn,
everybody.